I need a favor I need you to call your
boss and ask him to give me clearance on
the identification of this Source I
thought we just agreed that it didn't
matter yeah but I've still got to call
Walsh and tell him that I did everything
I could I would like to cover my own ass
check you're finally learning how to
play the game
that is the first episode of 24 where
Kiefer Sutherlands Jack Barrow must stop
a Terra plot in 24 hours the series
continued for more than 200 episodes and
earned the actor to Emmys now he is
starring the new series it's called
rabbit hole it's on Paramount plus a
division of Paramount Sutherland plays
John Weir he is a corporate spy although
he says he's not and a master of
deception who's framed for the murder of
a treasury official we must chase down
his enemies while on the Run himself
here's a preview
where are you chasing her
what's your Precinct what are the
charges
this woman has done nothing and they're
arresting her what are you doing I have
it all on camera answer him I see you we
see you we see back off
foreign
that is so intense Kiefer Sutherland is
here in the studio good morning good to
see you so good to see you guys and
before we get started I have to I have
to warn you a little bit uh during the
pandemic you know normally when I was
working I wouldn't get to see the
morning shows as much as as as as
certainly I did during the pandemic so
if I start to behave a little too
familiar with you it's because I feel
like I really know you uh oh wow a real
sense of normalcy for me uh during that
time that was so unnormal and abnormal
well I'm so glad because I thought you
were going to say so I don't really know
you all here no no
no no
that's so nice of you to say in a year
where I was wearing pajamas I would look
at glad suits and I would go like I'm
gonna go get dressed right now okay but
please flip that and play it forever for
me get a discount from your tailor yeah
thank you so thank you it's it's great
to see you in person listen we liked you
even before you said that now we really
like you
so wait let's talk about rabbit hole um
when you got the call for this I mean
I've read where you said thank God they
called me like well yeah thank God they
called me because uh uh our show Runners
uh John and Glenn uh are two of my
favorite writers uh one of their
screenplays was bad Santa which I
thought was one of the funniest movies
that I've seen in in 20 years and and as
directors uh stupid crazy love I thought
was one of the most well-balanced films
uh that I've seen in in a very long time
and so whoever they were going to call
was going to end up doing this job
um but I love the genre of the Thriller
and they wanted to pay homage to those
70s Thrillers like three days of the
Condors Parallax view Marathon Man uh
and those were the films that I grew up
watching uh as a young man that one day
if I was fortunate enough to work as an
actor those were the films I kind of
wanted to make
um well look at you Kiefer you're still
killing it listen we were only allowed
to see one episode yeah and I'm already
hooked I'm trying to you're out because
there could be so many questions so many
questions they're comparing Jack Bauer
and and Mr Weir and you say they
couldn't be more different well the
genre is the same so it is a thriller
and and and the kind of the Temple of a
thriller is that you take your lead
character you turn their life upside
down kick them to the corner and say now
run for your life and that's that's a
thriller and and that's very similar to
24. and that's very similar to this but
there's huge differences in the
characters uh Jack Bauer is the guy who
had run into a fight uh John Weir will
try and figure out how to run away from
a fight as hard as he can
um Jack Bauer uh and you have to
understand one of the greatest
opportunities I've ever had in my life
but as a character he was a he was kind
of a blunt instrument
um whereas John Weir is kind of like a
surgeon scalpel yes
um you know and he has some jerky
Tendencies yeah well for instance he's
incredibly smart and has this amazing
facility with numbers and he can make
these fantastic predictions uh but he he
suffers from uh severe uh
self-confidence issues and almost
borderlining on Neurosis so there's
these great contradictions in the
character that I hope the audience is
going to enjoy as much as I enjoyed
playing forgive my simple mind though
when it comes down to it playing this
character and you've known you're known
for your heroic rolls is John Weir a
good guy or a bad guy good question
again that's one of the things that I
love about this show it's it's up for
the audience to figure out and I think
John and Glenn have done such a
beautiful job in the writing of this uh
he doesn't start out telling the truth
you know I mean it is very obvious he
works as someone in the world of
corporate Espionage he's running an
operation which means he's lying and
he's conning people into corporate
estimate that he calls Consulting that
he calls Consulting yeah why are you
still doing your set your your own
stunts you don't have to do why do you
it's that it's one of the things that I
loved about 24 the physicality of that
character uh and and I haven't had the
opportunity in all fairness uh
designated Survivor was a very different
character uh and this was one of the
aspects that I loved getting back
through in the first fight sequence that
we did uh I was thrilled to kind of be a
part of it and then I realized oh it's
another difference between 24 and like
Jack Bauer always won his fights yes
Tony said that you are you usually pay
heroic characters but I say that you
started out when I was watching you in
your early days you're one of the
scariest villains in Stand By Me you're
one of the scariest movie villains ever
in Stand By Me the only part they gave
me I wanted to be one of the nice kids
but it was the part they gave me and and
always deliver keep yourself always do
so great we thank you so much you want
to take us to break you could read you
could
you know how to read Kiefer Rabbit Hole
premieres this Sunday on Paramount plus
and we'll be right back
[Applause]
to you tomorrow